savenay diamant on va devoir le cuir
moulant encore façon à bien contrôler le
pourtour le seul gardera effet à me paie
lui mm 1 cm la finesse que ça du coup je
suis chrétien
petit détail il faut avoir la pression
si la réfection mettre en place le
dessert du repas de la soirée caritative
dans la goutte et analyser ce qu'on veut
on fait couleurs et voilà qui est bien
sûr ce que tu crois que ça va trouver
mais ce que je dirai que c'est pour ça
que la seconde
bruce oeuvrons après on verra ça choix
de l'assiette on verra par la suite si
je crève oui parce que le faire la
difficulté c'est
l'élève doit trouver une entreprise
d'accueil mais il faut qu'elles soient
suffisamment structuré il ya une
pâtisserie avec un chef pâtissier donc
tous les établissements n'ont pas ça ça
se précise
[Musique]